and I think this is an opportunity for
you to sort of maybe help people
understand why you're accused of this
the 8 news now investigators first to
interview accused murderer Rob Tellis
the elected official answering questions
about the allegations and the evidence
against him and it's a story that our
investigators have broke online earlier
today we thank you for joining us at six
I'm Denise Valdez I'm David chard's in
for Brian tonight Rob tell us wanting to
talk about his family that domestic
violence charge he faced and what people
think of him as you'll see from our
interview he did not want to answer my
questions about why he's in jail
what's your message to people about what
happened
public administrator Rob Tellis did not
want to get into details about the
murder police say he committed
speaking from a cell at the Clark County
Detention Center Friday Telus who
remains an elected official getting a
taxpayer-funded salary said he was more
interested in talking about this 2020
arrest on a domestic violence charge
okay
hopefully clear the air a little bit
folks
you just want to take me down to my
public official I did not touch anybody
I haven't heard anybody I am just being
a pro Telus said he wanted to clear up
what's happening in these videos he says
he's misused alcohol and blacked out
would you say you had a drinking problem
and I'm your Clark County public
administrator tell us who voters elected
in 2018 was public administrator at the
time running a small office of people
who take care of the Estates of the Dead
investigative reporter Jeff gearman
reported on quote turmoil in that office
leading to teles's Democratic primary
loss in June what was your reaction to
Jeff gearman's reporting
[Music]
police say DNA found under government's
fingernails links tell us to the crime
detectives also showing video of a man
they say is Telus along with evidence of
a bloody shoe and a cut up hat Telus
didn't want to talk about any of it
after about 10 minutes
and that's how that interview ended now
Denise it is important to point out that
nobody but Rob Tellis has said that Jeff
gearman's reporting is untrue of course
we talk to people in that office but we
were honestly surprised that he wanted
to talk to us today so why do you think
today of all days though I'm not 100
sure but we know there were procedures
in jail uh and as we have reported that
he had attempted to harm himself he did
harm himself during that standoff we saw
last week so maybe those precautions
were dropped today we just don't know
whatever the reason Vanessa Murphy will
be covering his appearance in court on
Tuesday